اذا نذهب الان الى القاهره ومعنا من هناك
الناقد الفني طارق الشناوي يسعد مساك
استاذ طارق اهلا بك معنا استاذ طارق
سنتكلم اليوم عن النجوميه رمضانيه
الى اي مدى يمثل هذا الموسم مصنعا اليوم
للنجوم الشابه برايك
[موسيقى]
برايك نجم النجوم من الشباب اكيد كثار فيه
حابين يعرفوا رايك اليوم
نجم النجوم من الشباب مع كلمه شباب كلمه
واسعه شويه رمضان لحالي طبعا يعني
يعني اقدر اقول لك انه مثلا المسلسل اللي
هو بتاع رمضان هو جعفر العمده اذا اعتبرنا
انه رمضان لا زال شابا
وهو شاب طبعا يعني هو في مطلع الثلاثينات
من عمرهم محقق ضرر عاليه جدا برغم تحفظاتي
على السيناريو في بعض مناطق وبرغم اقترابه
من
مسلسل
بتاع نور الشريف كويس الا انه
محقق درجه نجاح جماهيري ضخمه جدا في
الشارع المصري والشارع العربي
يعني نجاح واضح بس اوريدي داخل على الخط
محمد رمضان الجديده نسمعها منك يا استاذ
طارق يعني شو في مثلا شابات جنسيات غير
مصريه
لحد الان اذا في حدا ببالك
لا لحد طب خلينا طب اديني فرصه لبكره عشان
ما اظلمش حد مؤكد ان في اسماء يعني تركت
الباب
وربما يكون
يعني رمضان فاتحه خير عليها يعني سواء
كانوا مصريين او عرب
او نجوم لكن انا اتكلمت على على نجم راسخ
يعني موجود في الساحه وبيقدر مع مخرج اللي
هو محمد سامي
بيقرا
يعني على موجه واحده مع الناس ودي مهمه
جدا في خلق النجم ان يكون على موجه مع
الناس في وجود طبعا
مهما كانت هناك
هنرجع لك في هذه النقطه بكره بس اليوم في
موسم دراما عم يظهر بقوه دور محاكم سوشل
يعني تبعنا الانتقادات اللي وجهت لرحمه
احمد في دور مربوحه اليوم يعني انت بتشوف
ان السوشيال ميديا صارت فعلا تتحكم بنجاح
او فشل الفنان في العمل درامي
مش بس الدراما والفن لا ده في الحياه
دلوقتي في الحياه السياسيه حتى سوشيال
ميديا اصبحت الجزء مهم جدا في الثقافه وفي
التواصل وفي انجاح البعض او افشال البعض
يجب ان احنا نعترف انه الفنان الذي يجيد
التواصل من خلال سوشيال ميديا يعرف
قانونها بيحقق نجاح
هل السوشيال ميديا صادقه مش شرط يعني درجه
الصدق هنا مالهاش علاقه بالقوه بس هي قوه
مؤثره برغم عدم صدقها بنسبه 100% ممكن
تكون صادقه بنسبه ما بمعنى ان ممكن يبقى
فعلا في حملات ضد عمل فني او ضد فنان في
خلال السوشيال ميديا يعني بيتم التنسيق
بين القائمين لان في كمان في جيوش من
الذباب بسموها ذباب الكتروني بيقدر ان هو
يوصل الرسائل او ينفي رسائل فعلا فبالتالي
التعاون مع السوشيال ميديا مهم قوي بتملك
الكثير لكن علينا ان احنا لا نصدق كل ما
نقراه من بيانات متعلقه بالسوشيال ميديا
لا في مساحه ما فعلا من عدم
احنا بنشكرك جزيلا
احنا مشكوره جزيل الشكر الشناوي ناقد
الفني من القاهره شكرا لك شكرا